hey wanna hear the most annoying sound
in the world
oh man these intros keep getting worse
well i just finished the new godzilla vs
kong the fourth film in legendary and
warner brothers monsterverse and i gotta
say
it's my favorite of the bunch so i
thought it would be fun to compare the
latest mammal reptilian smackdown with
the other films in the universe
including godzilla king of the monsters
kong skull island and 2014's godzilla
and there are some pretty cool easter
eggs that connect all four of these
movies but before we get into it
make sure to like and subscribe because
here we
go it's been 59 years since kong and
godzilla have appeared in a movie
together but only two
since 2019's godzilla king of the
monsters
and four since kong skull island the
first shot of godzilla vs kong is of the
sun which is featured in the very first
shot of
kong skull island the sun has long been
a metaphor for the story of icarus
remember the story of icarus whose
father gave him wings
made a wax warning not to fly too close
to the sun
skull island even ends with kong's eye
turning into the sun and there's a lot
of
eye symbolism throughout these four
movies speaking of icarus we see flying
leaf wings those spike beaked flying
creatures from kong skull island whose
latin name is icarus
folium here we get our first glimpse of
jia whose name means family or home in
chinese
and china plays a huge role in this film
with the entire third act set in hong
kong
gee i wonder why
jia is a member of the ewi tribe a tribe
we saw in
kong skull island marlowe says the tribe
doesn't speak much so it's left somewhat
ambiguous whether the entire tribe is
deaf or if it's just aegea marlow and
conrad were both named after characters
from joseph conrad's heart of darkness
which later inspired apocalypse now and
you can see how this movie
is inspired by apocalypse now kong rips
apart a tree just like he does in skull
island he's actually being contained on
the island for his own protection
according to ewi legend there can only
be one alpha titan
since the events of 1973 the year skull
island is set the perpetual storm
surrounding the island has moved on to
the island itself
it has killed all the eewy but kong was
able to save
gia that's why there's a massive dome
around part of the island and why jia
doesn't have any parents
here we see that this is monarch outpost
number 236
in godzilla king the monsters we know
there are several monarch outposts all
over the world but nowhere near the
amount in the 200s so it looks like
monarch has been busy the past couple of
years king the monsters is set in 2019
and godzilla vs kong in 2024
so five years have passed in the
monsterverse even though only two have
passed in real time since the release of
king of the monsters
now these intro credits are chock full
of little easter eggs and connections
with the previous films first of all the
style in which they are done
is the same as the intro credits in
skull island and the end credits of king
of monsters
we see kong using a tool here just like
he'll use later in godzilla vs kong
but we get a glimpse of him using these
tools in skull island when he takes a
propeller to fight off the giant skull
crawler the credits also mention the
holoworld a place we get to visit in
this film but only briefly mentioned in
king of the monsters
i knew it man the vortex was a tunnel
into the hollow earth
at this point the hollow earth is still
just a theory and dr nathaniel lind has
been discredited by the scientific
community for his support of it
he even lost his brother who tried to
venture to it years ago the hollow earth
is even hinted at earlier than king of
monsters in skull island when one of the
monarch scientists says
hey randy you're not going to believe
this the bedrock
is practically hollow this is later
expanded on by him when he says
it's called the hollow earth theory that
there are these massive
underground spaces isolated from the
surface world the credits continue with
mention of william randa and his
expedition to skull island in 73 will
randa was the monarch scientist
portrayed by john
goodman we see a picture of godzilla
shooting atomic breath into the mudo or
massive unidentified terrestrial
organism
the main rival titan godzilla fights in
the 2014 version we also get a breakdown
of kong's weakness
flammable attacks we saw this in skull
island when captain packard tried to
blow him up
using explosives his enemies include a
giant squid skull crawlers and
titans two of which we saw him battle in
skull island
we also see the main batty from king of
the monsters ghidorah an
extraterrestrial titan also known as
monster zero who was found
frozen in the antarctic ice in the bonus
post-credits scene of king the monsters
we see alan jonah one of the main
antagonists in the film
agree to purchase one of the heads of
ghidorah in king of the monsters we see
one of these three heads disintegrated
by godzilla
so there are two left bernie says the
head here
is connected to another skull in
mechagodzilla allowing the person here
to control its movements so this appears
to be where the two extra skulls wound
up
back in the 2014 version there's even a
hint at ghidorah in the ruins of san
francisco this might be a subtle nod to
an early draft of this version which had
godora as the main antagonist
but it was taken out by director gareth
edwards because he felt godora being an
extraterrestrial
didn't fit in with the film's wrath of
nature theme at the apex pensacola
station we see godzilla appear flashing
those blue atomic lights
in king of the monsters this is said to
occur when godzilla feels threatened
it's never
explicitly stated why godzilla attacks
here but it could be because this
eyeball is somehow connected to the
godora dna
neural pathway or that this place
contains skull crawler eggs after this
attack we get a headline saying
godzilla no longer tightens savior which
seems to answer the headline at the end
of the 2014 version stating
king of the monsters savior of the city
were then reintroduced to madison
russell one of the main characters from
king of the monsters
after the events of that film she tells
her dad dr mark russell who also
appeared prominently in king of the
monsters that godzilla would never
attack without reason actor kyle
chandler coincidentally was also in
peter jackson's 2005 king kong but
that's not part of the same universe
of course his character doesn't believe
madison and she turns to the titan truth
podcast
notice the triangle symbol here which
gives off huge illuminati conspiracy
theory vibes triangles are also used in
the monarch symbol and
even the apex logo has a triangle in it
dr nathan lin plays with a spaceman
figurine and i can't help but think of
the figurine used by ford in the 2014
version even though his is an army man
nathan is also introduced to ren
sirozawa the chief technical officer of
apex now it's never mentioned in the
film but he is dr ashira sirazawa's son
they share the same last name and ren's
father ishiro died
trying to revive godzilla in king of the
monsters it's ironic that his son now
wants to kill him perhaps he feels that
godzilla was responsible for his
father's death dr
ishiro sirozawa is named after ishiro
honda the director of the original 1954
godzilla and dr daisuke serozawa one of
the film's main characters
ishiro's father died during the atomic
blast on hiroshima hence why he carries
around his father's pocket watch which
stopped at the same exact time of the
blast the original godzilla in 1954 was
covered in keloid scars to show how the
similarities between the blasts he
endured mimic those of survivors from
both nagasaki and hiroshima while trying
to recruit dr eileen andrews nathan
talks about how kong's ancestors reached
skull island through the tunnels that
connected to the hollow earth in skull
island we see the bones of kong's
parents who died at the hands of skull
crawlers godzilla vs kong fleshes out
this history by showing a throne room
for kong lightly built by the ancestors
of the ewe we see these a giant statues
of kong and the hollow earth which
suggests they live there thousands of
years ago in king of the monsters we get
a glimpse of one of these civilizations
that predates the egyptians and romans
another clue that humans lived in
harmony with both godzilla and kong in
the past
in madison's room we get a paper cut out
of her mother dr emma
russell with the line villain or savior
dr emma was an antagonist for much of
king the monsters believing that
releasing the titans would bring a
balance to earth and that humanity has
turned the planet into a war-torn
polluted and parasite-stricken home
she later sacrifices herself to help
godzilla defeat godor
long live the king dr emma was
responsible for building a bio-acoustic
device called the orca to communicate
with the titans
this started as a prototype to keep
whales away from the shoreline using
echolocation in the 2014 version ford
finds a book on dolphins and
echolocation in his father's apartment
he had been using echolocation on buoys
to see if he could find the origin of
the thing that destroyed the janjira
nuclear plant the place that melted down
and killed his wife
funny enough in king of the monsters
madison has an email from npr news which
states
dolphins use targeted echolocation while
madison ventures further into her
conspiracies we see an entry for mothra
pregnancy theory which likely has
something to do with mothra's
transformation from her caterpillar-like
state at the beginning of king of the
monsters to what we see at the end
fun easter egg there is a mothra labeled
terrarium in the 2014 version when ford
and joe visit their old abandoned home
while meeting with bernie the neon signs
also includes some fun easter eggs more
eye symbolism here a sign that looks a
lot like the legendary pitcher's logo
the production company
and this weird looking carp seen in the
introduction credits of godzilla
and king of the monsters later in the
film during godzilla
and kong's first fight we see how even
the music carries over throughout the
multiverse
listen to these two clips and how the
insanely deep godzilla theme is
reproduced in both king of the monsters
and godzilla
vs kong
fun fact composer junkie xl who also
composed zack snyder's justice league
told director adam wingert in order to
do this he'd need access to the world's
biggest bass drum the battles between
godzilla and kong were hinted at in the
end
credits of king of monsters here we can
see some cave paintings
even mechagodzilla is hinted at if you
read the fine print in the article over
here which states
de la rosa went on to claim that monarch
was not only developing this mechanized
giant on skull island but had already
tried to create organic titans in the
past
but back to this first battle where we
get this shot of godzilla dragging a
destroyer after an anchor gets caught on
its scales an homage to jaws when jaws
gets those barrels attached to him
in fact the 2014 version of godzilla was
so heavily inspired by jaws
that director gareth edwards named the
protagonist the brodies after the family
from that movie
and opted to show godzilla for only 11
minutes in its two-hour run time
just like how spielberg showed jaws
sparingly in order to build suspense
we see godzilla use his atomic breath
here something we saw both in godzilla
and king of the monsters meanwhile the
bernie bros uncover skullcrawler eggs
skullcrawlers were those main evil
creatures in skull island
and it looks like they're being used to
test mechagodzilla's powers they even
stumble across an eye of one of them
from a previous experiment the gang ends
up being transported by hyperloop to
hong kong but it's never mentioned if
this hyperloop takes one of the hollow
earth's underground tunnels
or whether this is just a normal one but
damn that's gotta be one of the biggest
engineering feats of all time
kong makes it to antarctica although
this seems to be a different outpost
than the one monarch had in king of the
monsters which was completely destroyed
by godora one of the things i noticed
were the suits they wear have the
monarch logo on them even though the
mission is funded by apex and this is
likely an apex facility adam if you
happen to know why this is
just drop me a comment below when kong
and the team do make it to hollow earth
they're greeted by titans we haven't
seen yet in the monster verse the nuzuki
winged serpent monsters which
kong makes quick work of and enjoys a
snack something we've seen him do
in previous films as kong makes his way
to the ancient throne room he sees a
giant handprint of his ancestors which
makes me think of this image from skull
island
and what is your point we see
mechagodzilla easily destroying a skull
crawler and we learn that the mech is
only at 40
its full power and in order for it to
achieve maximum efficiency it needs the
power from the hollow earth
this power is what kong uses to charge
the axe he'll later use to defeat
mechagodzilla
there's not much we know about this axe
other than it was found in the skull of
a skull crawler and appears to be made
of a godzilla dorsal plate it suggests
that the feud between kong's ancestors
and godzilla's has lasted millennia and
we do know both
had other family members we also have
this glowing image of a godzilla-like
serpent surrounding the throne
almost as if it's protecting it i like
to think there was a time when both
godzilla and kong
fought alongside to protect the humans
from the skull crawlers but ultimately
failed resorting in them
and the ancient eewee to move closer to
the earth's surface we also see at the
end of this movie that kong and godzilla
team up together to fight as one and
become allies so we know they're capable
of living together
kong does get gravely injured in the
battle between mechagodzilla but
nathan is able to jumpstart his heart
using the pulse from the heave craft
which is said to have enough energy to
power vegas for a week funny since a
mudo nearly destroyed vegas in 2014.
thematically all four films deal with a
theme of abandonment
ford is abandoned by his father who goes
crazy in his search for answers
marlow is stuck on the island during
world war ii but later reunites with his
long-lost son after 28 years
dr mark russell is never around when
madison needs her and is only reunited
with her at the very
end of king of monsters and in godzilla
vs kong well he's hardly in that as well
choosing not to believe his daughter in
one of the few scenes that they have
together
then there's kong and godzilla both who
are the last of their kind
throughout all four movies they show a
genuine concern for protecting humans so
long as they're not under attack from
them just where they go from here
is uncertain with king of the monsters
underperforming at the box office
compared to its predecessors legendary
is likely waiting on how well godzilla
vs kong performs
before greenlighting another
monster-verse entry but what did you
think of godzilla vs kong i want to hear
your thoughts below as well as any other
connections i might have missed thanks
for watching everyone for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you